les sirènes retentissent s’abscov une
épaisse fumée noire s'échappe d'un
bâtiment au feu 10 à 20 drones selon les
autorités russes aurait frappé
l'aéroport de cette ville située au
nord-ouest de la Russie à seulement
quelques dizaines de kilomètres de la
frontière avec l'Estonie
une attaque de drone a été repoussée à
l'aéroport aucune victime dieu merci
l'ampleur des dégâts est désormais en
cours d'évaluation tous les services
sont sur place nous avons organisé une
réunion d'urgence et définit les
principales actions les autorités russes
accusent Kiev d'avoir mené une vaste
opération la nuit dernière 6 régions
russes auraient été ciblées par des
drones Ukrainiens scof brillance Kaluga
Belgorod ou encore la péninsule de
Crimée depuis des semaines l'Ukraine
intensifie les attaques de drone sur
fond de contrôle lancé début juin
des drones kamikazes comme ceci
fabriqués aux quatre coins du pays et
dont le but est aussi d'installer la
guerre sur tout le territoire de la
Russie y compris en son cœur à Moscou ou
une frappe avait endommagé partiellement
cet immeuble la semaine dernière en
plein centre-ville mais aussi en mer
Noire ou l'armée cible les navires et
les bases navales stratégiques